first of all congratulations are in
order i know you recently married the
love of your life todd what was your
wedding day like
oh it was beautiful it was what we
wanted it to be it was only todd and i
so it's only about us which is like that
moment that we definitely needed
so we're very happy that we got to
get married just like we wanted to get
married just him and i in same parts and
we will be celebrating with our friends
and family soon
that is so nice and so special for you
to just have that you know moment
together obviously a day of celebration
but it i can imagine it was a difficult
day for you as well with of course the
tragic passing of your mother how
excited was she for you to get married
to todd
well my mother was very excited for me
to marry todd she loved todd from the
moment that she met him i remember when
they first met they were talking till
three o'clock in the morning and i
literally just fell asleep on the sofa
and todd and my mom were still like at
it at 3 o'clock in the morning talking
drinking champagne
and my mom putting on her red lipstick
so she always she always loved todd
and um and i'm sure that you know that
day she was with us spiritually and very
happy that we finally got to do that i
think you know as a mom you always want
your children you know to be happy and
to be in a good place and you know i
know my mom always wanted me you know to
have that like a man in my life a man
like todd that she knew like would have
my back and would you know help the
family and support us so i know my mom
was very happy and my mom obviously
believed in marriages she was married
five times so she was always like the
one saying like you need to get married
you need to get married
i love that and just to know how much
you love todd that's that's must be such
a nice feeling that's amazing
how does todd feel about being a part of
all of this being part of the housewives
hmm well he didn't know it was going to
be so much about him
yeah you know yeah he you know a lot you
the truth is like he didn't sign up to
do this you know i did
you know so i think he you know i feel
like the first time that you know the
husbands are a part of a show like this
you know i think they're a little bit um
just like resistant and they're like
afraid you know they're not very
comfortable with it because like i said
it takes a lot i mean not everybody can
do these kind of shows
so you know i feel like you know i
signed up for it you know not him and
you know you don't get to see like
everything about him or everything about
me everything about our family you know
you only see certain things
so you know it's it's it's not
everything right i mean you just for
whatever reasons you know it tends to be
that way you know what makes the cut
but um you know we do have a lot of
happy times as a family and a lot of
great times and you know we're very you
know
you know together as a family but you
know sometimes you don't get to see
everything not in one season you know
hopefully you'll see more of that
oh good okay well speaking of family how
do your kids feel being back on the show
you know what i think frankie loves it
you know frankie loves being on tv yes
and um so he's very excited every time
we're gonna film you know he always
wants to be part of it
and um you know he's just like his
natural self and peter too i mean peter
wasn't like he knew that obviously you
know he would be you know part of my
story because you know in my real life
they're very much a part of my life so
it just turned out to be that way and i
think they're kind of like used to it i
think that because they started at a
young age it's something like that you
never forget and it's something that
it's kind of like once the cameras are
on again you kind of like roll with it
like it
like it was the first time
yeah i also want to ask you about you
know your new business venture with
frankie what was the whole inspiration
behind the beauty bar
right well i've always been into beauty
and fashion so that's always been like
my passion you know i had the magazine
which was you know very much a lifestyle
magazine so obviously you know a big
part of it was also fashion and beauty
so um the beauty bar came about i
actually was a customer there and i used
to go with frankie to do my nails
and um i had the opportunity the owner's
like you know what i'm thinking of
selling it like would you be interested
i was like oh my god no no i don't want
this like i'm not sure that you know i
want to do this right now
but um all the girls and his employees
which were like my nail techs and i
would go there for so many years we're
like please alexia bye you know you
would be great like you know we always
wanted like you know a woman
um
boss you know instead of him so he was a
guy like he doesn't get us blah blah
blah so a few months later i was you
know wrapping up the deal and and buying
the salon and then we decided to change
the name and call it alexian frankie's
because he's always there with me and
when he's not there all the clients and
customers are asking where's frankie you
know like what are you gonna bring them
so
so you know we we needed that you know
at that time that's exactly what i
needed when we bought it you know um
you know we had gone through so much you
know as a family and you know i was
separated from herman he passed away and
the magazine closed you know so many
things and i felt like i needed a
purpose i needed somewhere you know to
to go to like you know every day like
frankie and i together so you know that
really gave us you know a lot of meaning
and purpose and you know five years
later you know we're still there and and
business is booming and we love the area
and it's been a lot of fun for frankie
and i
that's amazing you know i think
something that so many of the viewers
feel really connected with you because
you are so open you talk about things
that maybe some other people might shy
away from you know of course you brought
up vermin how challenging or or not
challenging was that decision for you to
talk about his past his secrets and of
course about your father as well
right
so um you know i feel like when i signed
up to do the show especially eight years
later you know after taking this eight
year hiatus that there was a lot of
catching up to do
and you know i i knew that that time
would come so i felt like if i do do
this season you know i have to be
you know i have to tell the viewers you
know like what's been going on because
this is what these shows are about so
you know i didn't know what death you
know was gonna happen i think what did
make it easier for me was the fact that
it's been eight years you know that a
lot of time has also gone by from you
know herman's passing
and that myself i'm in a different stage
of my life you know my 50s i've grown so
much emotionally psychologically
spiritually you know i really
you know i'm just like open like you
know i don't care you know what i mean
it's like i started writing a book i
started putting like my words you know
it's a pencil paper and just kind of
like
therapeutic you know it was therapeutic
for me it was healing so all these
things you know throughout the years
have become
easier for me to speak about you know
whereas maybe eight years ago 10 years
ago it was like i don't want to say it
was like a dark secret because i've
never seen it as something dark as a
matter you know as a matter of fact i
just thought that it was something that
it was not okay to share but you know i
feel like in the world we're living
today like it's so much more open i
think it's made it so much easier for a
lot of people to really express
themselves and to kind of talk about
things that used to be taboo many years
ago and are no longer taboo that you
know they're part of many people's lives
and many families so i'm actually proud
you know that i have had these
experiences and that i have known how to
deal with them and accept them and um
learn from them and share my story with
other people that are going through it
as well
i love that you know when you are
putting so much of your personal life
out there and you were just being your
most true self you're going to have
people who
give their opinions or they want to
criticize how do you handle all that
well i don't read you know i really
don't read the comments so i i remember
years ago when i signed up to do the
reality show that that was always my
attitude you know it's kind of like you
know i don't care you know i
you know i have so much you know to
focus on that i don't have time like you
know to read those kind of things i even
like post a picture i don't even see
like how many likes i get or what people
are writing i don't care i just do it at
the moment and i disconnect so i have
that ability
that i don't let it affect me in any way
you know this show has never affected me
like my psyche you know what i mean
because i feel like some women it does
they like it makes them crazy or they
get very effective they think they're
like you know i've always been the same
alexia you know 10 years later 10 years
now whether i'm more popular now or not
it doesn't matter i've always like
really been who i am and i will continue
to be that person even now more because
i'm older i'm wiser so you know those
things aren't really going to affect me
but i feel like the best advice is that
like really not to read those things
these are people that don't don't know
you they don't know your life you know
and but it's like you say everybody's
gonna have an opinion everybody's gonna
judge you without really knowing the
story so i feel like
i have the platform and it's my
narrative it's my story so and this is
how it is nobody knows my life more than
i do you know what i've gone through so
man that must feel pretty empowering
that's awesome
so your tagline is so great my life is
like a movie and the award for best
drama goes to me so i need to ask if you
could cast anyone any actress to play
you in a movie who who would you love to
see
i would love to see margot robbie
you look like margot robbie
yes well no i wish yeah she's much
younger than me but i feel like i feel
like first of all you know i think she's
an amazing actress and she's had so many
different roles and i feel like she
could really capture like who i am
and how i am and she could probably even
speak like me like spanglish right like
she'll learn spanish she'll like yeah
she'll have the miami accent i'm sure
that she can do it i would love for it
to be her
that's so amazing okay so uh a few more
questions just as that we're wrapping up
um we definitely on the show uh got to
see peter and todd go at it and you know
it ended well but how would you describe
their relationship now
oh the relationship is great you know
because sometimes you know you have to
find yourself in an uncomfortable
position
in order to see the results that you
want to see you know sometimes you know
things it's really hard
you know when you're going through
things obviously you just saw it like
you know on tv but you know things
weren't that bad it's just like what you
saw and then we they just had like an
explosive moment and that's obviously
like what you saw
but like inside the intentions were
always good you know you can see the
love that they have for each other and
that they continue to have for each
other and it was just like i think that
that happens when you're so close and
you have so much love for each other you
know it wasn't like i mean we've been
together for five years so you know
we've had a lot of beautiful amazing
moments as family and we continue to do
you know you unfortunately only saw that
you know you haven't seen all like the
pretty beautiful moments you know that
we've had and like i said you know it
was really difficult for us to see
watching it back obviously it was it was
difficult for us when we were in it but
it was just as difficult when we saw
that on tv
because
it was so painful you know like to see
you know you kind of see like your
family like broken down at that moment
and um
so you look at it you cry you learn from
it we you know talked about it you know
as a family and you move on and the good
thing is that we moved on that very same
day i think after everybody got
everything off their you know their
chest yeah it was like we moved on we
like hugged it out we kissed and like
you know what this is going to make us
stronger than ever and it has you know i
think that we all like you know listen
to each other and you know we all acted
on what we needed to
act on and we all fixed what we needed
to fix and you know it's it's a work in
progress you know and i'm sure a lot of
families in america and all over the
world can relate to that
oh can they ever absolutely anyone who
isn't getting into arguments their
families from time to time is lying uh
this is what you do exactly what i mean
when you really care if you don't care
then you know you're not talking about
it you know you look the other way but
you know when the intentions are good
and you really care and love the person
this is what you do yeah so yeah we're
all in a good place so thank you for
asking good i love hearing that
you